The joe rogan experience,
the thing you posted today about the Florida headline.
That was something that was like the Florida headline for sure.
That was like what you said in the caption.
That was the jet.
Yeah.
I was um,
writing this bit about exotic pets and uh,
when I'm in the middle of this bit,
I just decided to start researching to Florida.
What,
what inspired you to write?
I'll tell you,
I don't want to do the bit right.
It says a Florida man tries to start naked bike club at chick filet.
A Florida man was arrested after he challenged others to fight and to stare at
his genitals outside of chick filet.
What did Dan Bilzerian say?
People can,
Florida just can't act right.
Trust me.
That's a good jab at himself.
Points points to Bilzerian for at least come and correct with that.
That's funny.
That is a ridiculous headline.
Also.
Where can I sign up?
It sounds fun.
It's like game of Thrones for methods.
Naked Fight Club.
Yeah.
Why not?
You want to go to watch from a neighboring parking lot with binoculars?
Hell yeah.
That's you want to do.
You want to know gate that you want to be far enough away.
So if they start running at you balls out dicks way June deep,
you're like,
don't you know zombies do keep your car in park engine running and then use
those by knows.
Absolutely.
You know,
I shut my Nami National Cheney's with your oven Mitt tee shirts.
There gotta be a video of that.
Right?
If someone was out at the chick filet itself,
there's not video.
That's it.
I'm very disciplined,
depressing fact there has to do some video video of almost any kind of
interaction with these days.
People create interactions so that they can videotape them.
Parents,
man,
they've got to stop putting their kids on video.
We've got to stop.
It's enough.
My friend's a doctor and I was talking to him and I used to,
you know,
it just popped by to say what's up and he goes,
hey man,
just to let you know,
the more you go to a doctor,
the faster you'll die.
And I go,
what?
Yeah.
He's like,
I just want to let know.
Yeah,
yeah.
He says,
the more you go to us,
you come to us,
the faster you'll die.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
Because a lot of doctors are crooked and they'll give you something for what you
think you got.
And then after that wears off,
they have to give you some else.
So now you just keep filling yourself with stuff to fix.
The other thing that was wrong and he goes,
some,
some doctors are not good people.
And he goes,
the more people go to doctors,
the fast day.
Dot.
Put it in point.
My Mom beat breast cancer twice,
right?
And my dad's never been to the doctor.
He's 75 years old.
Never been to the doctor wants,
because he's like,
well,
as soon as you go to the doctor,
they tell you something wrong,
you die.
You know,
literally.
But if you have cancer,
you should go to a fucking boy.
He didn't have cancer.
My mom did.
Right.
But if he had cancer,
he should go to a fucking dime.
I don't think he would go.
Even if he,
yeah,
he's just,
your mom beat it twice and she's still here?
Yes,
she is.
She,
the second time she be,
she didn't even tell me she had it.
It doesn't your dad want to beat it if he gets it.
It's kind of was like,
Hey,
I've been through a lot.
I'm fine.
Like he's,
he hates going to the doctor.
They'll only time we went to the doctor.
He had a back problem and that's it.
That's all score.
What have you met?
A good doctor.
Like a doctor that he likes,
like a guy he plays golf with or some shit that's like my dad.
My Dad is not social.
It's not,
no,
no.
I'm totally weird.
You're so social.
I,
I'm totally opposite.
Like my dad's story is crazy.
Like he,
you know,
he went through segregation.
He got a phd in nuclear physics.
Oh yeah.
My Dad's a genius but shit by out there talking shit on just telling jokes,
I'm a failure,
but you're not because you're a success at it.
So he's got to go all right.
Yeah.
He knew.
He's the one that told me to drop out of college.
Really?
Yeah.
I play football for the university.
Say it though.
He said you need to drop out of college.
You're not smart.
That's not supportive.
Michael,
you need to drop out of college and chase your dreams.
Oh No,
no,
no.
He was like,
my dad's whole thing is I got a phd in nuclear physics.
I know what wanting to be in school is and you don't want to be in school and
you,
you got a personality.
Go do that.
But you're dumb.
A long time ago,
my travels,
my uh,
my,
I was going to go do a one on butter being show down in Alabama and my parents
were like,
man,
you're going to Alabama,
be safe down there,
dumpy doing all that stuff.
He do,
you know,
it's going to be different because of,
America American,
our history with racism.
And
I went down there and I was,
you know,
this is what you might even tell the story again because this is a story.
So I went down there.
I was,
I was at the show and,
and some,
uh,
cops come up and they look like the cops from,
you know,
in the movies from the south that you're supposed to scare you.
And I took a picture with him and they're like,
and somebody else came to take a picture and you're like,
well,
look what we started going,
Oh man,
I'm gonna do this song.
This is what I'm here to do.
I mean,
you hang out with people.
I'm a referee fights and,
you know,
talk to people they want to talk.
So I took a lot of pictures.
They were impressed.
They are saying that,
you know,
they've seen other people,
tell people know about pictures and the guy on side it,
they're like,
hey,
we want you to come out and pull people over with us.
I'm like,
no,
I don't want to do,
I have no interest in doing that.
You know,
I grew up in La,
you know what I mean?
Like they're like,
and they're getting pumped it like,
imagine like you're getting pulled over by herb dean pitch.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I'm like,
no,
I don't want to do it.
And these,
uh,
then one guy was on,
he goes,
well,
we'll some do something.
I've been wanting to make this do some tase me or something hurting.
And so like,
he grabs this,
his taser gun and sticks to Taser in my hand.
Jesus sitting there and I'm like,
what the fuck?
So I started tasing him,
right?
I'm changing this,
he's in this guy.
And he's like,
I'm like,
ah,
I,
so then,
um,
I,
after the tasing,
uh,
his buddy,
one of the agents and one of the guys who was working with me comes up and tells
him that he has some business to talk about with me.
I go,
Hey,
what'd you want to talk about?
He goes,
man,
I could see you are so uncomfortable with what was going on that I just wanted
to get.
I was like,
thanks.
I get back to him.
I give that to my hotel room.
And I,
I was thinking,
I was like,
man,
you know,
I'm worried people prejudging and being an intolerant.
I'm prejudging of these guys because of,
uh,
some history.
And these guys are really cool.
If I ever get the opportunity to seize guys,
I'm going to be,
you know,
man.
And I,
and I did,
they came like right there and the phone rings,
I swear.
And they took me to an after party and really like,
yeah,
they took it like,
and it was like the place looks like roadhouse and you know what I mean?
Like the hell,
everything you see like in a movie,
like,
like you know some,
you know,
hey,
your wife's not going to be happy about that and,
and I'm gonna catch you next week.
One of those types of things drove me to the airport with the lights on school.
I think.
I think I still have the picture of me tasing them.
I could show it to you.
It was like,
it was a pretty cool experience.
So after that I was like,
man,
whatever.
I think I know about things.
I really don't.
And so,
uh,
so I take things at face value.
Yeah.
I've had good times in Alabama.
I've had good times in the south.
I think the world's changing too.
I really do.
I think there's parts of,
especially in this country,
we almost everywhere you can find cool piece.
So,
so yeah.
So I mean,
if,
uh,
you know,
oh my God,
that is hilarious.
So,
so that should put this on your Instagram.
Can you?
Yeah,
I can.
That they wouldn't mind.
I've talked to those guys about it.
Don't you think he's going to get in trouble though?
No,
he's not.
Gonna he said he's fine.
He said it'll be all right.
I thought he would get in trouble.
So I didn't want to,
he has,
that's why I haven't put it on.
That's why I never did that.
But I've actually talked to him,
I'm pretty sure.
So anyway,
this,
um,
that,
yeah,
that's a big lesson to me.
Like,
Hey,
don't,
don't think you know what's going on,
you know,
take things at face value.